property your animal courage
yes hold on I discover the people we got
another plate and had it down gasps you
got ready board make sure those if you
are the mic still going and the room
please convince I came here all the way
from Seattle take a lot of those with a
hilarious time yeah
[Applause]
welcome to Chicago hey you know you're
just you the Chicago your lunch Paul
handle bird oh my god I'm gonna get one
too talkative that to get a deep fried
pieces you Bryce officer looks like if
you came to my sit in Seattle and you
have to follow crazy ha ha ha ha ha eita
work please hahahaha comedy is one of
the more difficult art form sometimes I
wish I was a painter because I've never
been taking a picture and how they can't
this be like blue hahaha like a tree you
should quit something asian hahaha i was
being ancient i'm very proud the agent
whatever people are racist to me as what
they confused so like what you hate
respectful people do you see to the
throne hahaha ok let's finding an
affordable car ha ha ha ha artists
nowadays are like banning the recipients
are the worst people I just say this one
day one day because there's several
people so as I stopped smoking weed go
get a job move out on my basement
haha [ __ ] you immigrant haha this is my
country well people think maximize
destroying America I don't think max is
visited touring America I think it'd be
hilarious as they did destroy America
haha their lives America the greatest
civilization the world has ever seen
they were brought down by people helping
them because they manabis ever figure
this out go to America clean the dishes
bold Alonso he's busting up hahaha
happening people are blaming that kid
for being poor like it makes me feel all
my money it was my money the people with
less minus me took my money one of other
people are probably not the people with
the money maybe they took your money
because they have it sounds of people
without it they don't have it haha and I
work and I TV people they want to be
able to say hurtful words like [ __ ] or
[ __ ] but then they are really offended
when you call them racist or sexist
wickedness and a little [ __ ] now sorry
is trying to part of your personality
that's optional and you can change I got
a Christian as an Asian person was it
different because the people who of the
Bible didn't even see the doll that
Asia's existed click leave a drop of the
line page and print on the final word
Julie prob you back to the jeans are my
favorite yeah I am an atheist now
because another kindergarten and have an
interaction haha are they gonna be
stressful to other worlds you let me be
destroyed by back
bloggin on straight out of a possible
haha it's like this woman do this whole
time
like a portion I think abortion is a
great modern technology I think it
should be available to everybody because
if you only make abortion for people who
have money and know how to plant you're
only gonna board the birth babies hahaha
[Applause]
oh noes i'm going to go outside and very
quickly